[Music]
we are at the raviga hado
islands 300 miles from shore off of
Mexico and we're putting critter cams on
giant manta rays for the first time
[Music]
[Music]
the masses are so friendly that they
just hang out with the divers so we
wouldn't get any interesting footage
because we just you know get selfies of
ourselves from the mantas perspective
and so we actually had to institute a
policy among our group that once there's
a camera on the animal we get out of the
water so that it'll go do something
interesting I personally think that
mantas are one of if not the most
amazing animal in the ocean
they're incredibly graceful very
intelligent they're coming and
investigating you just as much as you're
investigating them
every other big animal that lives in
these open ocean habitats tends to
migrate quite a lot but fur manta is
what we're finding is that they're
pretty much staying put
I hope that the intrinsic value of
having mantas swimming around in our
oceans is enough to convince the public
to protect them but there's also a
really strong argument for protecting
them for economic reasons
I think that having animals like mantas
contributes to the planet that we live
on this is what makes the oceans while
we're out here putting critter cams on
leopard seals we saw for the first time
on video ever an act of klepto
parasitism